we are in the year 1095 just for context
this is roughly half a century after the
great schism between the Eastern
Orthodox Church in Constantinople or
centered at Constantinople and what
eventually gets known as the Roman
Catholic Church or the Latin Church
centered at Rome we have the Byzantine
Empire continuing to lose territory
remember in the seventh century Islam
expanded out of Arabia it quickly
overran much of the territory in the
Holy Land that at the time was
controlled by the Byzantines Byzantine
being another word for the eastern Roman
Empire by the time of this map Islam had
been in control of the Middle East the
Holy Land North Africa and even a good
chunk of that Berrian peninsula for
several hundred years as much as over
four hundred years as we get closer to
this time period you have the Seljuk
Turks continuing to eat into the
Byzantine Empire and taking most of the
Anatolian Peninsula also at this time
remember we are in the high middle ages
which is a time when especially Western
Europe is on the rise there's increased
agricultural productivity the population
is increasing and it's in this context
that the emperor of the Byzantines the
emperor of the Eastern Roman Empire
looks for help
Emperor Alexios the first sends a
delegation sends an ambassador to pope
urban ii and he essentially asked for
some mercenaries
to help him retake some of Anatolia from
the muslims well pope urban ii sees an
opportunity here it's been roughly half
a century since the Great Schism he has
his own internal struggles going on and
struggles with some neighboring states
he sees this potentially as an
opportunity to focus attention elsewhere
and so later that year in November of
1095 he makes a sermon at Claremont in
the king
of France there are varying accounts of
his speech but this is one of them I or
rather the Lord beseech you as Christ
heralds to publish this everywhere and
to purse which is another way of saying
to persuade all people of whatever
ranked foot soldiers and knights poor
and rich to carry aid promptly to those
Christians so to the Byzantines and to
destroy that vile race from the lands of
our friends when he's talking about vile
race he's talking about the Muslims who
have control of the Anatolian Peninsula
and of the Holy Land I say this to those
who are present it is meant also for
those who are absent
moreover Christ commands it and
according to this account he goes on to
say all who died by the way whether by
land or by sea or in battle against the
pagans shall have immediate remission of
sins so this is this idea of indulgences
where hey you do something for me I can
forgive your sins this I grant them
through the power of God with which I am
invested Oh what a disgrace is such a
despised and base race once again he's
talking about the Muslims which worships
demons should conquer people which has
the faith of omnipotent God and is made
glorious with the name of Christ pope
urban ii speech has an impact larger
than even he expects throughout western
europe news of his speech news of his
call to go and retake the holy land to
fight against this despised and base
race the muslims takes hold and before
the pope is even able to organize a
formal army you have someone by the name
of peter the hermit lead what's called
the people's crusade in 1096 and this is
often considered the first part of the
first crusade as they marched through
the Rhineland in what is now Germany
they massacred Jews several thousand
calling them Christ killers
on their way to the Holy Land and this
is a theme that you will see throughout
the Crusades even though the Crusaders
ostensibly were there to help the
Byzantines ostensibly to take back the
Holy Land as they travel through foreign
lands they often wreak a lot of havoc
even sometimes on the Byzantines
themselves but the people's crusade
itself was very unsuccessful by the time
they got to the Anatolian Peninsula
remember Peter the Hermit was leading
there were women there were children
there were untrained peasants fighting
they were massacred by the Turks when
they got to the Anatolian Peninsula but
eventually the Pope was able to organize
a more formal what eventually gets
called First Crusade and once again it
surpasses the Pope's expectations and
far surpasses Alexios the Byzantine
emperors expectations and even a little
bit frightning to him where you have on
the order of 100,000 soldiers coming
from Western Europe taking these various
routes by both land and by sea and in
they are eventually able to take
Jerusalem from the Muslims and both in
their taking of Antioch and Jerusalem
most historical accounts say that it was
quite bloody with significant chunks of
the cities being massacred this is a
later image of what it might have looked
like when they conquered Jerusalem and
from that time period through most of
the 12th century they maintained control
of the Holy Land this is what the map
looks like in 1135 and you might notice
some changes now the Byzantine Empire
has reconquered chunks of the Anatolian
Peninsula in particular the west and the
north and you see these blue regions
here which are known as Crusader
kingdoms
we can zoom in on these Crusader
kingdoms or Crusader States and what's
interesting about them even though these
Western European Crusaders and they
weren't called Crusaders at first but
they wore a cross on their outfits and
we're eventually called
even though their goal at first was
apparently to help retake land for the
Byzantines when they were able to take
the land for the most part they kept it
and they set up these Crusader States or
these Crusader kingdoms that you see
right over here that they're going to
stay in control of for most of the 12th
century as you get into the middle of
the 12th century the Muslims are able to
take back a few significant cities which
is going to catalyze the second Crusades
but then as we get to 1187 the Muslim
ruler Saladin is able to take back
Jerusalem which as we'll see in the next
video will instigate the Third Crusade